yes how are you what's your name yeah we
said I don't good riding my C team and I
split my heart oh it was just me yes yes
like it's like yeah I get it it's like
that's yes
[ __ ] them nobody honestly guys first of
all they didn't decline you one random
[ __ ] person that read your [ __ ]
declined you [ __ ] then you're wrong
you're wrong listen in my face I'm
telling you right to your face you're
wrong you're valuing somebody else's
opinion too much you're wrong
I I'm just telling this is not this is
not a debate you're [ __ ] wrong do you
understand
you're letting one random person listen
you do you understand how many people
would have hired me none who's got
Instagram in here
cool go to it right now please do me a
huge [ __ ] favor go to Instagram go to
Gary Vee that's my account go 10 11
posts back you'll see my report card I
was ranked 243rd out of 254 in my class
[Music]
243 at a 254 in my class you know why
because I knew it was [ __ ] for me it
might not people [ __ ] for you this is
about self-awareness you have to know
who the [ __ ] you are but for me it was
[ __ ] cuz I didn't need it cuz I
wasn't trying I didn't give a [ __ ] with
Saturn how many rings Saturn had
listen to me you can't let something be
valuable more than you you're pandering
to them let them come to you take that
same essay and post that [ __ ] on
Instagram with a photo and see what
happens see what happens let the market
decide not some [ __ ] middle
management person that read your [ __ ]
good of course it's true and when you're
young in 13 or 15 and 9 do you think you
got to change your [ __ ] up because you
don't know how it's played that's why
I'm here to tell you exactly how it's
played one [ __ ] person read your
story my dear and [ __ ] that person
[Applause]